deswegen werde ich ab jetzt auf jeden
kommentar antworten
ist das krass egal wo wir rennen einfach
wir rennen und man dann herein wie ein
hund um dein leben
wir hätten einfach dc kann mein gott ich
bin einfach 22
what the [ __ ] water flotter [ __ ]
servus leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer runde hat das ist so eine hektik
hier ist alles viel zu voll gepackt mit
mikrofon und mit gast das ist übrigens
nie live kollege von mir christian esser
und ja was apple store wieder verstecken
ja wir zocken heute einen sieg weil es
eine wichtige ansage zu machen gibt und
zwar scheiße ich habe keine ahnung wo
ich hin soll
ach so ich kann immer noch unter wasser
agent der beste leben das immer gut
trinkbar ist also christian ist ist
nicht so mein kräftemäßig unterwegs
deswegen werde ich mir noch mal sagen es
ist so passiert nicht so der meister
aber es ist so man kann hier
normalerweise ertrinken mann und kind
dann schaden aber bei haydn siegmann
blog ist kriegt man keine schade aber
jetzt zurück zum thema warum wir dieses
halben siege machen
normalerweise habe ich da nicht also für
normale aufnahmen es gibt was
anzukündigen zwar habt ihr bestimmt
mitbekommen dass ich jetzt diese
challenge cup jeden kommentar antworten
sollte heute wirklich sehr fleißig
nochmal props an euch
der videomanager hat mir gesagt dass ihr
430 kommentare geben
ich konnte dummerweise nun wissen wir
jetzt sehen also ungefähr 120 bisschen
ärgerlich aber ich habe alle geantwortet
ich sehen konnte
und ja da habe ich mir gedacht es
eigentlich richtig gleise kommentare zu
beantworten deswegen werde ich ab jetzt
jeden kommentar den untermain video
schreibt persönlich beantworten
und ja ich auf alles antworten was
mitunter schreibt so lange werde ich
antworten und die usa oder die treppe
aus hier schon das wasser da so
jetzt habe ich ein schwert man kriegt
man noch weiter erschwert krass eine
richtig heiße action für was zum boxen
die haider ich kann es auch wenig
gestikulieren ich muss nicht zocken ist
perfekt die halter das wissen wir also
die sich verstecken und die sticker das
sind die anderen
diesen krasse crypt die analysten also
die beste rüstung die es gibt und
verzaubert nummern minecraft und auch
ein diamant schwert also verpiss dich
mal an die boxen hat sich noch ein
bisschen komisch an so wird man ein
thema in den sand stecken
nein keine macht der junge ja genau
wir sind halt haider wir verstecken uns
wie sieht's inhalt von außen aus wie
solche blöcke wie das ist hätte ich so
ein stein penis nasen konstrukt im
gesicht alter richtig dumm wir haben
keine rüstung keine rüstungs punkt was
ich hier keine bonuspunkte ein
holzschwert das ist ziemlich laut
außerdem warten ja nicht so dass es dazu
stehen wir
stille wasser sind tief verschneit
die belastungen sind
und ja wie gesagt also schreibt dann ab
jetzt wenn ihr irgendwas wissen wollt
ihr mehr sehen wollt dass kanal eure
katzenschnupfen hat oder sonst was
schreibt einfach in die kommentare ich
werde jetzt nach wegen kalter persönlich
antworten
und ja ich glaub das einfach cool weil
dann bildet sich wirklich so eine
community mir persönlich gefällt auch
nicht so denn wenn ich jetzt mal einem
größeren youtube als ich noch eine
nachricht schreiben der einfach nicht
antwortet das finde ich einfach scheiße
da fühlt man sich so ja gar nicht
wahrgenommen und das möchte ich halt
nicht bei euch also ich möchte sie euch
wahrgenommen fühlt von mir deswegen
werde ich ab jetzt auf jeden kommentar
antworten
ist das krass ziemlich krass das sind
jeden tag 20.000 stunden arbeiten und
ich sage jetzt gar nicht mehr
und ja die sache ist die ich mich
verstehst haben wir gar nicht wieso man
das nicht macht ich meine gerade in
meiner größenordnung ist es halt echt
noch möglich und ja ist einfach cool
wenn ich mit meinen abonnenten und
zuschauen so gut verstehen mit denen
schreibers beste das ist beste und hier
ich versuche hier ein bisschen abzubauen
mit dem holzschwert aber das
funktioniert natürlich nicht
zum achten mal raus werden er macht ihr
60 sekunden 60 sekunden
60 egal ob aktion wir retten einfach
rennen wie ein hund um dein leben alter
nein aber nicht ärmlichen hütten ein
politiker und mein gott ich bin einfach
nach 22 uhr ab doch fakt what the [ __ ]
so kann es gerne etwas verkackt jetzt
sind wir auch noch
ja ich habe punkte bekommen hier soll
auch uns morgens und points ja das war
jetzt besser da wir hätten einfach noch
locker sie hier gewinnen können 7 sie
konnten sieben sie konnten ja ja
die polizei die eine sekunde
fakt vortag das war jetzt ein bisschen
bisschen he sik mäßig ja wir schauen mal
wie lange schon aufnehmen joh 6 minuten
sechs minuten 2 die machen halt ein
kurzes video oder warum jetzt ein
richtig lang machen
langes okay das liegt zwar hoch aber
dann machen wir das und wir sind seit
kurzem kann wieder jo leute das immer
wieder ich zeig' 3 for no reason keinen
grund und ja wir versuchen jetzt gerade
mal ein bisschen uns zu verstecken
müssen obhut place und ich weiß gar
nicht was hier unten so also dem ausland
ist gar nichts metrisch 97 sekunden
kommt schon die syker gott oh gott noch
nicht fertig fertig ist einfach überall
ist einfach überall mit plugins die säle
verstecken
auch müssen sich die institute
warum ist damit eine truhe
die spitze nein mach doch die tür zu a
du bewegst du dir auch nichts kaputt was
ich heute mache die fucking tür zur ko
alter nein ja ok aber gar nicht so dumm
naja leute zu eurer informationen auch
wir kennen uns aus dem studium wir sind
sozusagen studienkollege wir sind jetzt
beide im zweiten semester als kate jetzt
keine erste meister mehr ein erste her
und ja da hast du mir so macht ist ein
paar käsestraße klären sketches und al
qaida gut ist alles wissen alles können
haushalt trotzdem ein bisschen
deplatziert und kartmann
das ist doch so offensichtlich leute
bitte nicht ich kann nur hoffen dass ich
sie irgendwie anschleichen der bindung
oder so leiden ob es wirklich hat
ungefähr einen la stw
ja das war jetzt ein bisschen dumm sich
auf seiner web wo alles aus kurz gemacht
ist als roßkopf zu verstecken
wir schicken jetzt noch kurz mit ihm und
ich weiß jetzt wo alle sind dann immer
vorausgesetzt dass der andere die jetzt
endlich kaputt gemacht hat gehe ich da
jetzt mal hinter alles kaputt kam schon
cup in schaan kommission
red ribbon wie sagt der rapper apple
gangster 600 denn so oder so was hier
oben lebt auch nichts mehr nur noch ja
ich hab ich verplappert ist natürlich
keine keine die rüstung ist nur bleiben
sie aber stört einfach nein quittierte
quickie sind diese ganzen typen auf 116
117 sekunden 114 sekunden mit ihren
booten
da habe ich auch mal schon perfekt
versteckte kamera zu 320 personen ist
wieder ein beispiel seltener echtes
selten einfach sowas obst freundes du du
du bist du mein freund dass gleich ob
das schadet kriegt ja doch trägt man
sogar kanal roma-politik sterben
rochaden die stars hier ist nichts mehr
upstairs danach krank bist ein bisschen
krank
mit dem partner was ist da los war nur
sind diese fucking sieht hunderten von
fans sind die wo hatten die sich
versteckt wo helfer die sich versteckt
kann ich sein angaben sind so viele sika
einfach richtige sieger bekommt man kann
den entertainer nicht
aber verkackt ich heiße was haben wir di
diri mehrheit das nicht gefunden hat
haben sich manche besser versteckt als
wir
wir sind jetzt bei knapp 13 minuten
schon zwölf wenn ich kannte ich weiß
nicht gar nicht und ja also zum
abschluss noch mal die seite ab
letztlich auf jeden kommentar also
schreibt fleißig in die kommentare
wenn das video euch gefallen hat geht
einen daumen nach oben wenn ihr mehr von
mir und reallife kollegen sehen wollte
und nicht immer nur so furios los und
ferien und so
dann schreibt man das in die kommentare
und zeigt
und ja nee so denn heute ist nicht
gegenteil tag heute so und ja wie gesagt
was ich gefallen hat mir und da würd ich
sagen macht's gut und achtet auf den
kopf schütteln
gerade hat er war ja ich bin mega
behindert leute behindert werde würde
ich sagen macht's gut habe einen schönen
park umstellen